hey everybody brocco team mol here to
wish you a Happy Mall day from all of us
at Khan Academy yes
lulz the chemistry concepts that's
critter now in case you've been living
under a rock like me a mole is another
name for Avogadro's number which is 6.02
times 10 to the 23rd kind of like how a
dozen is another name for 12 so why do
we need a name for such a big number
well we could write it out like this
thank you but then we take away
moles make counting easier for chemists
particularly when talking about atoms or
molecules so for the number of molecules
in a cup of water you could write an
eight with 24 zeros after it or you
could just call it 13 moles of water
instead thank you it's that easier now
the moral of this story is Mo's are the
best and if you want to learn more about
chemistry or anything really head to our
website khanacademy.org that's Khan is
in Genghis no relation and Academy as in
Academy happy mole day everyone you can
learn anything
we still we're not recording